hello on a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
the German capital Berlin and this week
we're looking at the latest developments
in the war in Syria where the focus is
very much on the embattled city of
Aleppo in recent days the city once
known as the jewel of Syria has seen
some of the most horrific fighting in
the five-year old conflict a quarter of
a million people are under siege there
are allegations of barbarism and war
crimes local medical staff say they
simply cannot cope with the overwhelming
number of casualties one first responder
said of the situation in Aleppo there is
no escape it feels like the end of the
world so here on quadriga were going to
be talking about the suffering of the
people of Syria and the response of the
international community and to do so I'm
joined here in the studio by three Syria
specialists beginning with Lezama Felix
da da he is a German Syrian author and
activist based here in Berlin and he
says what is happening in Syria is an
abomination and will continue as long as
Washington refuses to exercise strategic
leadership also with this is Christine
helberg who's a widely published
commentator on Syria she's convinced
that the path to peace in Syria goes
through Moscow and we're joined to buy
DWS own my soon Melhem she was born in
Syria and says it's not Aleppo that is
the real cause for shame but the
suffering of all the Syrian people and
the fact that the international
community has been in denial for so long
well my son Bellamy I'd like to begin
with you you were born in Syria and we
have tended in recent times to act as
though the conflict in your country
could not get any worse now it seems to
be there as a definite escalation what
are your thoughts and what are your
feelings well you know you start your
day with a cup of coffee and somehow
feeling of satisfaction that's your
child is sleeping in his bedroom and you
start reading the news and
the first thing you see like what I saw
today a bunch of children swimming in a
crater explosion crater and resulted
from the bombings of yesterday filled
with the water of the broke water supply
which the civilians living in Aleppo
don't have anymore and they scroll down
and then you see Bashar al-jaafari
laughing at the UN the ambassador of the
Syrian regime at the UN laughing when a
journalist a shocking moment truly a
shocking moment asking mr. ambassador
did you target the two hospitals
yesterday so he just laughed and walked
away and you think well it's been it's
been like moving from bad to worse for
the last five years and unfortunately
it's not getting the worst I mean every
day we reach a worse condition I don't
know if I'm gonna have an end in here in
any anytime soon mmm Kristen helberg
after five years of this out five and a
half years now of the conflict in Syria
Staffan de Mistura the un special envoy
to Syria he spoken out and said that
they we we are now witnessing new
heights of horror what can you tell us
from your personal contacts it's
definitely a new escalation and I always
thought as you probably all thought that
it's it's not possible it cannot get any
worse but it's getting worse and we're
only looking at Aleppo we have other
places where people are besieged by for
four years now that we are not even look
at you know we have studied the strategy
of the Assad regime to to beseech people
to bomb them continuously to starve them
out you know and this all works because
Bashar Assad himself and the Russians
now know that they can do whatever they
want they can use the bombs and the
weapons that they have because nobody
will interfere and stop them so this is
the major problem right now okay before
we bring you in Osama let's just listen
to two voices from whoohoo of people who
are trapped in Aleppo at this current
time required FL autobody I call on
honorable people to come and help us
we're dying with a blockade the
destruction and the killing you thought
or what they may God hold these people
to account must have been unloved when I
meant you don't got it and well which
country did we rise up against were
simple people we've committed no crime
the entire world including Russia and
America is crushing us suzama Phil
xterra that's very very moving testimony
directly from Aleppo I've noticed in the
last couple of days a lot of people
would be comparing the situation in
Aleppo with the situation in gann occur
in 1937 just be in the build-up to the
Second World War and people have also
been talking about what happened in
Dresden in 1945 at the end of the Second
World War the terrible fire bombing of
that city how useful are those kind of
comparisons well I think they are useful
comparisons to put a context there I
mean if you want to look at ya nico or a
dayson they were destroyed in a fairly
fairly quickly in a matter of several
weeks but in Aleppo or in other places
in Syria that have been besieged for
example in darya in southern Damascus
here you have a civilian population of
Six to 8,000 people with six hundred
fighters that were to be besieged
literally for three years and they could
only survive because they have their
independent water supply the old Arabic
houses have very deep wells and they're
really into urban gardening but in terms
of the context of the [ __ ] we see now
in Aleppo this is a very long protracted
situation so it's it would be comparable
to what happened in Warsaw when the
Nazis besieged the city there or the
Jewish quarter there it only held out
for it for 21 days now Aleppo has the
stamina and the willpower I think to
withstand for many months so what we are
seeing is definitely comparable to that
but is it is on a much larger scale and
it's it's like dying in slow motion mmm
when we talk about the level of the
suffering how important is it as well to
2.2 the the kind of weaponry that is now
being used cluster bombs and etc napalm
and bunker busters and incendiary bombs
how important
all that now well how important is it I
mean these are these are weapons that
that are that we've seen we have a
regime that has unfolded it's complete
conventional military arsenal and we
have a white house that has said we have
international norms that have to be
respected and enforced there was a red
line drawn but not enforced the murder
weapon was taken away but he was not
punished for it in terms of chemical
weapons and then the UN started a a
process in which the regime became a
partner in a disarmament process and now
23 years later we see statements from
the White House saying the use of
chemical weapons has become routine in
Syria I think it shows that we have to
go much deeper here that the very
foundations of the international system
as as we know it as we knew it since the
Second World War is fraying it's falling
apart my soon you are nothing well I do
agree with him especially when I was
when I always get a disappointed that
not only this red lines are not informed
they enforced Bashar al-assad and his
the representative of this regime which
is doing all the attractive atrocities
which we are witnessing right now he
gets interviewed by interest
international journalists like every
couple of weeks so he had he is given
the chance to justify his war crimes in
front of all our cameras after doing all
his crimes also in front of our cameras
so I don't under I really don't
understand it and these journalists come
usually from the US from the West not
even from Russia who was obviously
supporting the regime well I think we
have to take into consideration that the
students are really paying a price for a
mislead Western foreign policy of the
last 10 to 15 years it's not that simple
you know if you look at the American
record in the region obviously there was
a lot of mistakes you had an invasion in
Iraq that was the
birth moment kind of dash of the Islamic
state the so-called Islamic state then
we had Obama came to the White House
saying that I don't want to go for any
military adventure here I only want to
get American soldiers home so this was
the second catastrophe for the Syrians
because then we didn't have any chance
to engage militarily to the only aim of
protecting civilians it's not about
regime change here and I don't want to
compare it to Iraq because it did not
happen there's no Western regime change
if there were any governments who wanted
to do this they would have millions of
reasons to do it you know talking about
the red lines but we don't have this
year we have a US administration and a
European continent that is not able to
to formulate any kind of common foreign
policy so we really left Syria to Russia
they took the chance they engaged very
much even militarily so this is why we
are now at a point that we have to
realize if we like it or not that it's
the Russians who we need to convince how
to get to a future inside Syria and this
means that we have to have kind of a
negotiated transition without Bashar as
that in the end so the Russell's have to
understand that this is in their very
interest because in the engagement and
the war in Syria is very expensive for
the Russians and it's not popular at
home and the Russians cannot own Syria
it's just too big for them so it's in
their very interest to get to this point
to make a transition and organize
transition away from the Assad regime
wood elements of the opposition with
elements of this regime that have not
blood on their hands as they say and we
have to convince radomir putting off
exactly that because without him it's
not possible but how I mean we have been
watching peace talks between even
between directly between the Americans
and the Russians for the last I don't
know how many months now it seems he's
not interested that's the problem so
maybe we need a military balance here
that's that's a question do we need to
engage militarily for a no-fly zone to
you know to stop at least the bombing of
civilians unilaterally from the West do
we need this everybody's afraid of
escalation everybody is afraid of a
third world war with the Russians but
will it not maybe be a step to get out
of this spiral of violence you know
maybe it's
just about you see this is exactly what
was tried in Geneva and the first six
months of this year the opposition was
there they had three rounds of peace
talks and of course there are several
tracks and it's exactly as you said this
is what what what the goal is to take
the remnants of state institution civil
servants who have no blood on their hand
and to and to try to go for some type of
an interim government and a military
council to disarm and so forth but I
think there's a huge problem here if you
see that diplomacy fails that has a huge
huge price it doesn't occur in a vacuum
and as if you frankly look at the u.s.
position here going into Geneva they
have a plan a and they declare that
every day there is no alternative to
diplomacy but if you don't have a plan B
if you don't have a credible threat of
anything plan a cannot work and I'll
tell you why because the Russian
ambition grows with their perception of
weakness in the White House and of
course it's not so easy as you mentioned
also i mean russia its economy is about
the size of spain now it's in free fall
you know their their foreign currency
preserves have fallen from I guess 130
140 billion down to twenty percent of
that now perhaps even less they don't
want to swallow Syria they can't and and
they're fighting to hybrid wars in the
Ukraine and in Syria at the same time so
you have to have some type of a balance
there so that each side can even opt in
sense how far they might be able to go
in order to just consolidate the
situation and we're nowhere near that
because the Europeans frankly I think
they can formulate a coherent policy but
it's only coherent in terms of what the
lowest common denominator is I mean we
spoke of barbarism last Saturday the
Security Council met on Syria and a very
interesting exchange of blows there the
US said Russia is responsible they
called them their actions barbaric the
Germans did not do that they waited and
followed the American line and when the
Europeans came out with their statements
miss Morgan
the two days later she didn't mention
any culprits at all she just said that
that's very disconcerting so it shows
there that there's no military
components at all and I think that's
just the opposite of what we learned
conventional diplomacy to be you know as
Teddy Roosevelt said speak softly but
carry a big stick okay I'd like to pick
up on the word diplomacy before we move
on with the conversation let's just
listen to what four of the top
international diplomats have had to say
in recent days imagine the destruction
people with the limbs blown blown off
children in a terrible pain with no
relief infected suffering time with the
nowhere to go and no end in sight
imagine a slaughterhouse what Russia is
sponsoring and doing is not
counterterrorism it is barbarism Brazil
touch in the territory see as a result
in Syria hundreds of groups are being
armed the territory of the country is
being bombed indiscriminately and
bringing peace is almost an impossible
task now Stella watch t.v was Mosley's
Adachi there is a failure of the
international community that's what the
Syrians are saying and they are right
thank you very much thank you
people of Syria are saying that the
international community has let them
down i know that you say the
international community is in denial
tell me more well as i said this drama
we are watching on TV now is more than
about just a typo it's been like this in
Helms like for two years or three years
even from 2011 where there wasn't any
million Ne Islamist or she had this in
Syria till 2014 that was like this and
that' and Madam EA and as Osama said the
Syrian regime did many many things or
crossed many red lines which was drawn
by the international community or by the
US and wasn't it wasn't even asked about
it we heard only rhetorics on from them
and I mean just a couple of weeks ago a
convoy of aid organization or some some
aids coming going to the civilians and
Aleppo was targeted by Russia and no one
even raised an eyebrow about it mmm
christen her by the question there is
how can one deal with Russia of Russia
is responsible for barbarism and for war
crimes and for destabilization I mean it
really the last week it seemed quite
cynical you know they were all sitting
there around in New York trying to go
back to any kind of truths and at the
same time it was really the Russians
itself bombing east on airports and it
seemed very much yes cynical from a
point from a Syrian point of view but
but again we won't be able to to find a
solution without the Russians because
they are there they had their own goals
in Syria they I would argue that
Vladimir Putin kind of reached his goals
already he wants to be perceived at the
world power as a as a regional power
that is very cruiser to the region he
wants to make sure that the American
Century has kind of is over in the
Middle East you know that he is a very
important player there he wants to make
sure that his own military bases will be
at our tools that the coastal side I
think this is all what he needed from
Syria so now it would be the time for
him to realize that if he wants to kind
of influence the post-war era and who
comes and who follows the Assad regime
it would be
really now the moment to ask Bashar
Assad to step aside the problem is who's
going to tell this to Vladimir Putin and
why is he not realizing this I feel that
at the moment the deal between assad and
protein is this Assad says okay will we
will let some humanitarian aid convoys
pass because this is what we are seeing
at the same time we have several cities
that received some help during the last
week at the same time he really wants to
go back to East Aleppo he really wants
to take East Aleppo he has tried to
several times he will stop by the
Russians this time he says we will
finish this we are so close so the
Russians will help them in this with the
hope that after this new election in the
u.s. because that's the biggest fear of
staffan de mistura there un convoy he
said that you know this conflict will be
frozen for three to four months because
nobody will engage and we'll think about
any international initiative without a
new US president so this is really
dramatic because the Russians will help
Assad to fortify his position literally
on the ground and then everybody has to
wait until februari probably 2017 until
any other international initiative will
be pronounced but did I understand you
right that the Russian are not able to
impose their word on Assad in there are
they don't seem interested I think they
are doing this so they're waiting for
him to take it back in the city or the
part of the city which is held by the
rebels now and be satisfied and then
they might talk to him yes I think this
is what you're okay I think if I can
just make a comment here it's really
interesting that when we speak to the
Russians we say your problem is that the
guy that you're protecting is the worst
war criminal we've seen for a very very
long time and this rubs off on you and
he's also very weak on the ground I mean
the Syrian army is only legally carrying
this title it's basically dissolved into
a bunch of warlords and we set we see
the results with the last so-called
elections in Syria the Parliament is
full of these warlords it's not the bath
party anymore just all these thugs
they're now in trend traders who were
funding some front but the army itself
cannot hold a single front this is what
the this is by the way of what Russian
military zone Russian generals just a
lot of them
really complain about this i mean look
look what we got ourselves into now the
other aspect is what is happening on the
ground here if we say the international
community should should balance out
something it's just not going to happen
without Hillary Clinton right and the
opposition is already speaking to
Hillary Clinton she has a Syria task for
six or seven people and basically
reassessing her options means what means
trying to separate the Free Syrian Army
which is there they have tens of
thousands of people there in the North
there in the central and part of Syria
and in the south it's not a drama though
it's not an army it's an idea is the
idea of a revolution and of n of an army
that that keeps its oath that it's war
to protect the the fatherland and Syrian
citizens which which nobody does in the
Syrian army now but the problem that I
see we have from now until februari say
Hillary wins what is going to happen in
this interval now and this is where
Putin is going all in trying to you know
try to destroy Aleppo this will give
them a much stronger negotiating
position and what it means for the
international community is that Syrians
are saying well as a matter of fact
jabatan Laura and these jihadists on the
ground are a morally stronger force than
the international community they give
their lives to break I mean this is what
they see they feed us and so forth this
is a huge problem okay we talk about the
Americans we talk about the Russians my
soon what about Bashar Assad and his
supporters I mean I you know I guess
that down the years you've had plenty of
opportunities to listen to what they
have to say and I'd be interested to
hear how that sounds to you at this
point in time because they too are the
Syrian people yeah they are well as any
other part in Syria there are some
extremists they are living in the condom
in the region where Bashar Assad still
have the controller and upon but many
people are just tired from this war from
this long-term war and they are just
stuck there hoping to leave the country
even if they support Bashar so whether
they just hope to leave the country and
leave it behind
survive with their souls and children
and I mean like many other many other
who we hear from them the the same
statement we we've been hearing for the
last five years what might what might be
the alternative official aside went and
now it's about their existence there I
mean after the war is being between
jihad ease and she 80 militants and like
after it's become a sectarian war and
they are just defending their existence
there or trying to leave the country and
I mean it has become a self-fulfilling
prophecy I mean yeah that's up from his
very first stilt and they invented at
the beginning but they are suffering a
train right now and conspiracy and
foreign terrorists coming to the country
which was ridiculous everybody was
laughing about this and then but they
did not nothing but they were not
laughing they believed it from the first
moment yeah but now they see that on the
other side you have all these jihadists
so in the end yes Bashar Assad is
supposed to protect me from these people
yeah a lot of his supporters of people
who just told still you know don't move
they are afraid and I think that they
just feel you know let's not let's not
move I mean they they are afraid of the
Assad regime of member secret services
there obviously but they are afraid of
the future as well so they time to they
tend to believe what he what he's
telling them and by the way they are
they're even afraid of serving the army
so they support him but they wouldn't
like to fight in his army mm-hmm there's
something that I'd like to add here I
mean it's true of course you know he's
he this is his self for fulfilling
prophecy Assad you know to destroy all
the moderates so the world has to choose
between him and basically Isis or Al
Qaeda or whoever um and the Syrians are
stuck with people saying look these guys
protect us we don't share their vision
for a future Syria at all they don't
even use the word Syria true jihadists
cut but he's the only one protecting me
now where is the world and when I speak
of the interval until the next u.s.
president hopefully decides to make a
move there's a very important point you
see eighty percent of Syria are hard to
reach areas
you have according to the Geneva
designation you have 18 or 19 besieged
areas and eighty percent are hard to
reach those are almost exclusively
provided for by Syrian civil society
which is still alive and what I'm afraid
of is that not only the political
discourse and the negotiations are
actually sort of you know trying to
trying to find a meeting of interest
between the great powers and Andy and
the neighboring countries the Syrians
are shrinking away from this process I
just don't see them as strongly I don't
see them being consulted I mean how can
you how can you have a process there and
a cessation of hostility based on an
agreement that you do with with Russia
as the u.s. that you don't consult with
your allies and your friends with I mean
you're you're doing this for the Syrian
people aren't you you know it just seems
to a lot of Syrians that they're
improving their bilateral relations at
our costs and it shouldn't be so talking
about the Syrian people and we made
shame the shame in the international
community one of their one of the topics
one of the focal points of this
discussion Pope Francis talks about the
globalization of indifference towards
Syria 30 seconds on that phrase i think
the UN or the international community
has not only let Syria down in terms of
war or warming but the humanitarian aid
is not being delivered to people there
because the UN has really lost their
impartiality and their neutrality inside
serious the Assad regime who dictates
who gets the help and ninety-six percent
of the food held for example which is
only a sense area so we have to go back
to more to stronger stand a
globalization of indifference I would I
would really say sadly the sentence you
told me before the show injustice has
become a part of our moral system the
last word I would just ask the European
states to not think in terms of their
national interests in their national
agenda if you really want to help the
Syrian people you you invest in civil
society it's still alive and it's the
future of Syria okay we'll have to leave
it there I've got to say thank you very
very much for all of my guests thank you
for your comments thank you for your
insights thank you for joining us here
on quite
do come back next week until then
bye-bye and chest